Rahl is with us in Albuquerque hey how
are you hi great how about you good how
can I help
thank you so much for having me on I
really appreciate it sure so I have a we
really need some advice as far as our
mortgage goes on my family home our
mortgage is currently in the foreclosure
process payments haven't been made in
about eight months now why there is one
so we had some family circumstances
change about almost two years ago we
lost my mother and in the time being you
know my father has moved on and he
hasn't lived in the home and she's you
know lying to forget and move on and so
given what's going on with the home I am
looking for an apartment I'm looking for
a place for myself as you know I I'm 24
okay so your mom passed away yes two
years ago and then your dad just packed
up and left no no no it was about a year
later that he moved he didn't move far
he was up the street but he wanted to
move out of the house okay cuz she
passed away he met someone he met he met
someone you yeah what why didn't he oh
he met someone new yeah he met someone
new so he's in build with her now and
just decided to just walk off from his
mortgage not necessarily no he stopped
paying the mortgage not not too long ago
less than a year ago but you know our
what we were planning to do is was to
sell the house there is no we you don't
own the house he does right he does so
this is what I wanted to ask so here's
the situation with the mortgage there is
still 161 owed on the principle the
house is valued
maybe I'm high in about 170 but in the
life of the mortgage 40 had been
deferred because I think there might
have been a point where they had fallen
behind on payments when I was a teenager
something I'm not sure exactly but at
this point with 8 months past due
there's about 12,000 passed you now what
I figured is that you know was based
upon my mental math I figured that with
what I spent in
renting an apartment in maybe about five
years I could probably catch up on that
40,000 and the 12,000 so I'm wondering
if for the sake of sample of saving my
family home if it would be a wise
decision for me personally to take over
payments no just for the sake of saving
the family home No and to take it out of
the foreclosure process now no the
family wasn't interested in saving the
family home only you are and you're 24
years old and this is a payment you
can't afford and it's a situation that
you're starting at sub-zero you're
starting below ground and I wouldn't
start below ground at 24 years old I'm
sorry this has all happened to your
family and this it sounds like a whole
series of things that are heartbreaking
have gone on for you but don't compound
that with getting stuck in a mud hole
here and mathematically financially
that's what you're getting ready to do
this is not a good deal for you you yeah
you can start at zero and you'll be
better off rather than starting below
ground 40 grand our 12 grand or whatever
and right it's not your it's not your
fault you didn't do it
it wasn't your responsibility you didn't
sign up for this right well one of the
original plan was that I would inherit
the home s own plane and so me you know
I you know live a while you know I've
traveled the world that's what I wanted
to do when I finished college and you
know I'm feeling ready to take on the
responsibility and I feel that if I
wanted to honor my mother's memory if I
wanted to doesn't honor the moon doesn't
click on mine you have to take on life
in my inheritance I would be willing to
take on the responsibility to help catch
up the catch up the mortgage it's not
and be here Albuquerque also not an
inherently stevemartina giving someone a
pile of debt is not an inheritance
giving them an asset is inheritance and
this is not an asset it's a mess
and what do you make a year right now
I'm not making much you know right now
I'm still as a server and I'm an intern
so
about twenty on a high-end maybe
twenty-five right now but I did just
apply for a full-time position that pays
about forty five a year but if that
doesn't work out I'm gonna go ahead and
work pretty hard to find a full-time job
that that makes me a you know a better
living yeah well you need to do that for
you that's a good career move on your
part I don't know what messages have
been sent through your family but if
your dad walked off from his
responsibilities on this for his new
girlfriend and left a twenty
four-year-old server holding the bag
that's right he doesn't necessarily want
me to bear the burden either I know I'm
just willing to take it on any
obligation if you don't need to be
willing you don't have an obligation
right if zero obligation to this
situation and it's not good for you you
don't have the money to handle it it's
gonna bury you and there's something
toxic draw to this for you and and I
just wanna I'm gonna try to set you free
from it and maybe your mom wished for
other things to be wished for things to
be better I mean if they had if they had
left your home that had $200,000 for the
equity in it and you know you could
scratch and claw and come up with
$12,000 and save that that's fine this
thing's got no equity and it's over your
head you know it's not worth scratching
and clawing and coming up with twelve
thousand dollars to save five thousand
bucks of equity right so you don't so
determination to do you know to make up
for it
enough to take it on that you know the
the the the payoff for the lift is not
there especially given that you're not
in the position to do the lift anyway
it'd be very difficult for you
mathematically to pull this off but it
might be worth saying hey work six jobs
go crazy if we were saving 200 grand or
something but we're saving five thousand
bucks and you're taking on the payments
you can't afford mm-hmm it's just not
good yeah yeah and then I figure in the
short run yeah it would be it would be a
pain to catch up but I figure in the
long run once
you know have a better job a better
career you know I can make it to where
the mortgage payment let's pretend
you're living work let's pretend you
were living in a friend's basement and
we're not paying rent yes someone called
you up and said hey I've got a hundred
and seventy thousand dollar house I will
sell you for nothing down it has no
equity but you can see you can buy it
for nothing down and move in and start
making the payments you wouldn't do that
today you're not in a position to do
that that would not be a blessing you
would not look into the future and go
well it could pay off eventually
eventually I could get it paid down that
might be a good deal no it's not a good
deal because it's not a blessing it's a
curse at that point it becomes something
you can't carry so I'm so sorry you guys
are facing this I'm sorry you've gone
through all this heartbreak and letting
go of this house is a little bit a
little bit tight of the grief of your
mom I can hear that in your voice and
hear how hard you're fighting for this
but you have no moral or legal or family
obligation none whatsoever in this none
this is not a blessing your family does
not want you to take on a curse if they
do your family's toxic and your dad just
decided he didn't want anymore he's
letting it be foreclosed on he just
threw up to throw up his hands and
walked away you know and please don't
pick up his mess and call that an
inheritance it's just not your best
inheritance is the memory of your mom
the good parts of your dad that you know
about and you take those and you move
that into the next generation and you
move that into your future and it's not
about a house there's houses on every
corner please walk away from this please
you call from my advice sir and the Dane
it's a dangerous thing to do because I
will give it to you I will do everything
I can to help you even against your will
sometimes and that's what this show is
about